he is the number five weltered weight in
the world we flew him all the way from
chicago it is below muhammad on this
week's food truck diaries and i'm
feeding them pacos
mexican egg rolls on this week's food
truck diaries let's go
from my wallet to my check i don't want
it if it's skinny but i need it if it's
dead
need a thick girl
[Music]
i need everything
[Music]
what's up brother how you doing bro you
are not a small welterweight my man
people look at me like dang i don't
think you're that big yeah you walk down
yeah damn because you can't cause you
you do a lot of like analyst work and
when you're sitting down i'm like he's
not he has a big head but his body you
know he's like you know you got a head
on you so it's like he has a big head
but his body but then burst like oh [ __ ]
he's a big ass welterweight yeah i get
that uh jason herzog tell me that he's
like man when you when i was in the cage
with you i was like man you're thick
yeah yeah
yeah people underestimate it but that's
when they feel it like they're always
sitting there when they're when they're
fighting me like they always think that
i'm weaker than i am and then they feel
they're like oh all right you're a lot
stronger than i thought yeah and i guess
what's interesting about you is you have
so many like fire the night you're
exciting fighter and you've won what 10
on your last 11 like yeah on a streak
man you know you look at like the wonder
boy fight the damian maya like a lot of
your fights like you incorporate a ton
of wrestling
so i it makes sense like wrestling's in
your background but you're not like a
national champion wrestler but you're
out wrestling these dudes at you know
especially wonder boy you talk about
that wonder boy fight for you it's like
to me when i look at your resume you
look at your career 10 out of 11 you're
doing the damn thing
you know that wonder boy fight that's
when you want to that's a feather in
your cap because a
his takedown defense is ridiculous
that's all he focuses on yeah he's all
good on cake boxing you know what i'm
saying like his entire camp is just him
against the wall trying not to get taken
down and you just took him down over and
oh you know 50 45. yeah that was that
was literally probably the one that i
was like all right now i belong here you
know when you get to those fights you're
like all right i beat damian maya but
then they're like well you know damn is
old you're like all right maybe damien
is old and then they offer me
wonder boy and i'm like
damn wonder boy and i was like i've been
in camps with like anthony pettis who
fought him i've been on campus with t
woodley who fought him and they're
bringing in specialist karate guys
they're bringing in this guy that guy
and i'm sitting there like bro i got
their type of money i ain't and i'm
cheap so i'm like yo i'm going to fly
somebody in yeah but i'd like you know
what let me let me call up like a stage
north carolina maybe give me a look i
hit him up he's like oh sorry man i
can't come i can't it's like damn all
right so i guess just me on my own and
my team and i was like well what's the
way to beat him it's wrestling and it's
going hard and then after i got that
fight it was like fight week and i was
sitting there like everybody's telling
me i'm gonna get knocked out everybody
tell me he's gonna spin the heel kick
man who's everybody fans you know the
the cat online yeah and even my manager
hit me up it was like fight week or
manage to hit me off he's like ah
brother man you know i'm excited about
who's your manager ali
he's like
everybody with that brother you know you
know what you know we had to take this
fight because you know we had to show
that this top five guys we had to take
it i'm sitting there like all right yeah
i know i want this fight i know he's
like uh you know but you know what i'm
most proud of proud of is that you know
we got you an analyst job and i'm like
bro you're talking like i'm about to
lose and yeah
yeah i'm like bro what are you talking
about i don't like that literally i'm
like
yeah do they really think i'm gonna lose
right now that's how it goes though yeah
that's how it goes especially when you
fight big names because they have such a
big fan base and they're so well known
like even your manager your friends your
family your brothers like wonder boy man
because they've seen the head kick and
the spin back kicks and all that [ __ ] so
that gets planted into your mind but i
think
there's moments in fighter's career and
even up till then you've beat some
monsters again 1011s in the welterweight
division
in current ufc days is
nazos it's absolutely nutsos but that
wonderboy fight again when i look at
your resume that's the one and as you
said like you want to see if you have
what it takes to be those top
echelon guys for me i remember walking
out they gave me gabriel gonzaga the
time he's ranked in top 10 in the world
i remember walking out going dude if you
can't beat him let's go get a job
because you're never going to be like a
top if you can't be him yeah like you're
not
you're just gonna be a god yeah so i
remember walking out and i felt so kind
of relieved i was like yeah that's cool
now here's the decision you don't beat
him you'll go get another job dude yeah
so for you and i'm not saying get
another job but i think for you like
that wonder boy fight who remember he's
beat two guys
that beat me he beat you yeah so you
have that going into it so you have all
in your managers like hey man you know i
put a thousand bucks on wonderboy
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you have all these things working
against you then you go in there 50 45
pretty clear yeah you know what i'm
saying so it's like off to the races
after that my man yeah after that one it
was like all right i belong this is me
and then you know you get you get a
little cocky but then all of a sudden
the trolls are still there well
wonderboy sucks anyway i wonder where
are you going to wrestle oh daddy you
weren't saying that the weakness
literally i'm like literally going back
to my comments of the fight week you
can't win that you're going to you're
never going to win those you're never
going to win those yeah and then like
you listen to like joe rogan like don't
put that negativity in your head stop
reading the comments but i'm like
posting goes brother post i try i try
but it's like you want to read because
you're like maybe they're going to start
telling good things about you now and
it's like no nothing's ever going to
yeah because it's their reflection on
you it's like they could never do what
you do so it's like their like own
insecurities they're lashing out at you
that's why you got to look at it so and
like think about this before you're
starting ufc career if you're like hmm
i'm going to take a
vote on instagram if they say yes i'm
going to pursue the ufc go hey guys do
you think i'll make it as ufc fighter
it'd be like 90 10 like hell no because
yeah of course not yeah that's why
they're throwing hate your way you know
what i'm saying like you're crushing it
man but 10 out of 11. and then that's
what i like about your story so you got
wonderboy thompson which has to be a
mind [ __ ] it's like be two guys that you
lost to yeah you know he's impossible to
train for you have a small camp your
manager is betting against you but you i
love you but you get it done you get it
done and then they go okay what what
else would be the a bigger mind [ __ ]
than wonder boy oh let's give him a
vicente luce as the main event a guy you
lost to was it your second fight yeah
second fight he knocked you out which is
awful like so just meant to get over
that and not only do you have to get
over that but you're the main event bro
yeah that was the fight where i was
taking such a hard path i was like man
the ufc hate me i was like they they
have to have to have something to
against me so i'm like you know all
right you give me maya i'd be my one of
the best grapplers i've ever fought in
the ufc then you give me wonder boy
who's one of the best strikers ever
fought in the ufc then you're like all
right well i think he got past those two
let me give him somebody that knocked
him out somebody that one of the best
finishers i think one of the best
finishers in the welterweight division
at all and it was crazy how it came
about because at first they were like
you're fighting comes that uh main event
in london and i was like
all right let's go book it and i'm you
know i'm telling my family let's go
we're going to london and then all of a
sudden ali calls me like
ah brother hold up we got an issue and i
was like well he's like well if you
fight comes out in london then luke and
gilbert are not gonna have fights and
you know they're never gonna fight each
other and i was like okay and then he's
like
so pick one of the three and i was like
if i'm picking one of the three i want
comments because you gained the most
from beating a guy like that 100 and i
was like let me get him and he's like
all right all right hold up hold up you
know what's gonna be you and gilbert
then luke and kamza then i was like
whatever and then he called me again the
next day and he's like
hey yo it's gonna be you and luke and i
was like how do you keep switching off
why did you even ask me yeah it sounds
like you had a plan yeah yeah
something you knew before i was gonna
answer yeah yeah i'm like all right
whatever bro let's go and then like you
said it was still the
you're telling everybody yeah it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter but it's the
guy that knocks you out in it
and to have a guy that you know puts you
to sleep and you're getting those like
the trolls that are sending the same
gift every freaking day you know when
you're getting knocked out and you're
like i can't get past it and he's
yeah that's the other thing is yeah he
beat you but you've both gotten a lot
better but as much as you've gotten
better vicente luca has gotten a hell of
a lot better too like he's a savage dude
yeah and then
main event turn ramadan
during ramadan
who is dude hey ufc cut my boy of some
[ __ ] slack they're like here's
vicente all right you beat wonder boy we
get that impossible match up now here's
vicente luke again who knocked you out
and we're going to do it during ramadan
and go muhammad you know
i tell myself that all the time because
i did the maya fight i had to do the
whole canter and i was like never again
i'm not i'm dying this is the last i
earned it where i don't have to fight
during ramadan again but like i said ali
calls you and he's like all right
they're going gonna do you and luke but
he didn't give me a date
then i was like all right cool
did he tell you main event he told me
main event and i was like
yeah somebody says i'm gonna say yeah no
matter what and then all of a sudden
he's like yo it's this day i was like
well we did it before
and then your coaches are like bro this
is that when you're at top five
you got to be a little bit smarter now
and i was like bro it's main event and i
was like
i have to take it and then just to get
that one back otherwise i'm a fighter
too so it's like oh he turned it down so
he's scared of the guy that knocked him
out yeah no i get both sides yeah i i
wish
your manager in the ufc be a little
friendlier to you but yeah they're not
doing any favors so again you get past
the wonderboy test you pass the luke a
test main event and then here we are
here we are and to be honest before he
came in i called trail sony because i
used to i like to bounce ideas off jail
for the division stuff like that
you're in a tough position my man the
division's in a tough position because
you've got kamar usman who's you know
the pound-for-pound goat right now
welterweight you know some i think even
rogan dana said best of all time you
know it's debate for that i i actually
agree with that but so you have this
goat at the top he has to have hand
surgery
so we don't know what's going to go on
there he's supposed to fight leon
edwards so you got that right yeah let
me paint the bakes for you this is how
messy it is so you got the you got uspin
and leon edwards and leon has earned it
that that poor guy has earned it we have
history with leon to poke you in the eye
so you have leon oozman here and then
you got over here you got colby and
hamzat two guys that i would love to see
you fight and we're waiting to see what
happens there the problem there is kobe
got sucker punch and mate might have
some brain damage from it and a chipped
tooth and there's a lawsuit so we know
what's gonna happen there
and then here's muhammad you know what
i'm saying it's like
you between the guys who have been
[ __ ] over the most are you and leon
edwards yeah and that's why i feel like
we deserve to fight each other but like
when you're when you're looking at it
this way i'm looking at it as all right
usman
he's earned the right to you know heal
up you fought three times last year you
have an injured hand you don't want to
rush your champion back
if i'm leon edwards i haven't fought i
fought one time in three years against
nate diaz
and do i want my next fight off of a
nate diaz fight to be the champion
or do i want to get in the cage and if
you think you're the champion you got to
beat everybody anyway yeah so why not
fight somebody
and even i'm sure usually would be the
type to be like yo do you enter in title
that's why i think i'm gonna be out
that's why i think think i think there's
a interim title i think
if colby and hamza fight on abc and was
that july or august do we know uh i
think that that one's in uh july yeah so
if they do that abc and they figure out
kobe and hamza i think that fights for
the intern yeah that's what i think
for me i don't think kobe's going to
take it though i don't think kobe is
going to fight kamza i think
you know like you said i think the
if he goes to court saying that i'm
accepting a fight then the court's gonna
go yo you're talking about you have
brain damage and we're suing this guy
you're taking a fight you're taking a
fight how how are you training right now
if you have brain damage
for me like you said i think i'm gonna
get obviously brushed over if it's
they want comes out to be the next one
to fight so let's you on the nbc like if
kobe can't give up the lawsuit which i
think you should yeah if cole we can't
give up the lawsuit and he wants to you
know put his foot in the ground and ride
on that cool
you do you figure that lawsuit out jorge
and you are out of here yeah so uh ding
ding ding ding mohammed for 5 000 alex
and literally i make it the easiest ever
i'm sitting there calling on everybody
i'm accepting it and then comes us
another one of that was like we were
going back and forth on twitter a little
bit and he's like posted a gift of me
getting knocked out by luke interesting
and i'm like
beautiful all right you do it yeah let's
go yeah you do it let's get it and i
think it makes sense when you're looking
at the top five in the division
uh gilbert's ready for usman kobe's
ready for usman leon's actually fought
him already but all right well you give
them that shot but me and kami's are the
only two that are fresh blood that
haven't fought him yet
and i just beat a guy in luke who was
the
he was going to be the substitute if the
the last time i played that yeah luke
luke i thought he was going to get a
title shot or be a late replacement like
to fill in there or he thought he was
going to get like a nate diaz fight
that's what he when he was on food truck
and that's all he's campaigning okay
yeah yeah and it made sense because his
streak was so so much so like all right
well i take his juice now since i just
beat him yep so i think ali hired that
uh
dump truck to interrupt this interview
ollie be cool man
well so we're continuous let me feed you
some mexican egg rolls
because you don't have a fight coming up
yet so we can't eat so let me feed you
these mixing egg rolls hopefully they're
good we'll continue this let's go eat my
man
i need a thick girl
i need a dick
i'm good man thanks for doing this
uh
uh mexican egg rolls correct
it's it's just like uh it's just it's
it's a natural but we're just filling
them up with mexican food would it be
like a deep fried mini burrito right uh
kind of like a chimichanga just not flat
oh gotcha right got round though right
what do you what do you recommend
everything we put on there is good man i
mean everything we make if we want to
eat ourselves it wouldn't be in our menu
makes sense
what are you thinking man they have this
in chicago no no never heard of mexican
grill yeah but we do have great mexican
food in chicago yeah yeah chicago has
great food yeah pizza is overrated
though right am i right am i right a
little bit i'm a thin crust pizza anyway
oh it's about the deep dish we have
great thin crust spots in chicago that
are really good yeah but we just don't
get the credit because everybody thinks
about chicago they think deep dish but
we got some really good thin crust spots
deep dish is trash yeah i'm not a deep
dish guy i don't really like lasagna
yeah
what are you doing all right uh
man i'm trying to think that carnito's
nachos one sounds nice
that's actually nachos yeah oh gotcha
that's straight up nachos yeah those
introduce the fries right yeah that's
just just the side ones right here oh i
thought it was like notches and they
just take like
right yeah
uh which one would you recommend though
like for a first time for us
the video is really good which one's
that where's that at on it's i i kind of
forgot to put into it random center
right that's right oh i see it what's
that one that's uh that's uh it's beef
but we do a marinade and we marinate
overnight and uh
and it just has really good flavor it
has a bunch of chilies inside we got
four different kinds of chilies in the
in the marinade
and then we give that with the side of
consomme which is the aju pretty much oh
gotcha that goes with cilantro and onion
inside but get down the side as well
those tacos are popular in chicago bitty
and tacos really yeah they make yeah
comes like its own little soup right
right right yeah that's the consummate
uh i'll do that in the carnitas nachos
okay let me see you don't have anything
scheduled so you can kind of go oh yeah
yeah
you don't want to go
you don't want to go paddy pimlet crazy
oh my god like literally i was in vegas
and i was like no way you're really that
big like he's legit huge did i do a food
truck i was like yeah
oh you did with him i was like bro what
the nachos come with uh uh it has sour
cream guac that's jalapenos pico de
gallo yeah fire it up man everything on
it okay i'm trying to [ __ ] my pants
okay
aren't you on all meat diet too yeah
yeah my only cheat meal is these food
trucks oh really so we do two in a week
it's not good but
we can you don't do no veggies at all no
nothing yeah i eat like a big cat at the
zoo my man yeah well my cousin was doing
it and then like we went to a restaurant
he's like oh i'm gonna cheat a little
bit he got like a salad i said you cheat
with a salad yes there's not any
vegetables at all and i was like all
right no this this is cheating yeah and
i'll feel terrible for the rest of the
night really yeah but yeah you can't
really be on a diet on a food show yeah
it's like the worst show ever so that's
what that's all you're gonna take oh
yeah i know whatever okay
i'll get the uh the media and uh the
chicken tinga
okay there's no pork or anything in
those right
no we uh chicken thing has chicken media
media's beef okay cool awesome brothers
uh i got diet cokes you got rice water
or nah i don't have no rice water rice
water
oh yeah
yeah yeah okay so i'll get these out to
you guys thank you man thank you
remember i used to dream about this [ __ ]
before i grew up how i put the team on
if i blew up i'd get the money for the
click and get the crew up and now to
crew up
not
[Music]
[Music]
we are yeah yeah they just trying to
help but i don't need no one they just
they just trying to help but i don't
need them at all i just went and did
some [ __ ] they never seen before going
back and forth let's switch them up
take a little break from chatting with
bella muhammad on this episode of food
truck diaries because man maybe you
don't feel like
getting up early working out whatever it
is you've lost your motivation or you
just can't fit into your busy schedule
all good well if i told you you could
work out from home that's right there's
peloton i have one in my crib i got one
in my freaking garage pelton that's how
i got started on my bike career man i'm
still on there but not been a member for
six years i've owned a bike for over six
years my name on there is thick prez
with a z thick boy prez it's thick boy
perez you'll see my username follow your
boy i love peloton man peloton has a
team of world class instructors ready to
motivate you 24 7. pelton has thousands
of live and on-demand classes so you
always keep it fresh and the music say
what i love the music they have edm
hip-hop rock whatever you're looking for
we got you man maybe we're looking for a
10-minute upper body stretch between the
calls or a 40-minute run on the pelton
tread whatever it is i like the 30
minute tabitha all right the tabs that's
my favorite with robin whatever you're
looking for you can get a great workout
in right now is the perfect time to try
out peloton the peloton bike plus is now
500 bucks less it's the best price ever
including free delivery and setup and
there are more game changing prices
available on the original pelton which i
have
in the peloton tread the treadmill visit
onepelton.com to learn more again visit
onepeloton.com to learn more now let's
just let's get back to the program
all right my man uh it it looks it looks
good
nacho standard they went over the top of
the notches makes them flag that's cool
uh but you know egg roll mexican
looks legit
first time trying to make it
miss stacy
oh yeah the same one yeah it's good
it's really good oh wow yeah yeah it is
nice
in uh in chicago where's your go-to i
mean chicago food man
what's your go-to's
for me and uh
i think we have some of the best
steakhouses in chicago a great hundred
percent what gibson's
downtown i go there gift is really good
rpm uh steak is really good too
yeah you guys have great steakhouses
yeah and it's one of those where you get
to the point where
i had the point where i was like eating
out literally probably like four times a
week after a fight because you're like
you're celebrating
and you look at your bank account
statement it's like bro i spent like
a thousand dollars this month this time
yeah and then for my culture it's like
if we're eating out i'm gonna pay for
the meal like if i invite you out and
it's always like that and you're like i
yo these meals are starting to get six
hundred dollars yeah i think you gotta
start going split build on this it's not
it's not even in my culture but i think
it's a culture of fame you get a little
bit of fame everyone's like oh brendan
has this i'm like i guess yeah yeah
and he gets it out yeah he gets to that
aggro point where he's like
but ninety percent of the people i hang
out with they're all like oh no let's go
let's play it let's play it it's me it's
me it's me it's not like they're not
pushing it on me i'm never gonna let
yeah i'm never gonna let them take it
over me
no because you i mean you surrounded you
came up with what three brothers uh yeah
three brothers and a sister that big fam
dude yeah so oh and you're we're at i'm
in the middle you're in the middle yeah
so you got how many older brothers am i
my i got one older brother and older
sister and then two younger brothers oh
dope yeah and they're huge fans i'm sure
of what you do yeah yeah my brother's
the
they're the ones that like my older
brother want to like push me through it
to do it more than anything like even
when i was in college like he bought my
first car for me he was like oh you
don't need to work do this do that yeah
yeah he was like giving me money
whenever i needed it and then uh
you know even with my cousins i had
cousins where i worked in their store
and they'll like set up the schedule for
me where i could go train so like i
worked the morning shift from like nine
to four
because they know the vision yeah and
they see it and they see that i'm
dedicated and they wanna they want some
they want me to get out like even when i
went to school because i went to college
and it was always like be different you
know 90 of the people that i know it's
like right when you finish high school
it's like i could work in the store i
could work in a business get paid cash
and then that's what everybody does you
open up your own business you build your
own money then you open up your own
store everybody does that everybody
thought that it was never about school
but but
i'm sure obviously have the support but
did everybody think you were going to be
this damn good you know 10 out of 11
what's great division 2 on 22 and then
also number five in the world like
you're
either your next fight is for an interim
title or you're one fight away from
fighting for a world title like that's
the only way i see it
my older brother was uh
the type right when i got into the ufc
like give us matt brown give us carlos
connor tom stop
doing that to you and my coach like bro
we gotta build up no no he'll kill all
of them and he's like telling me that
i'm like bro shut up this is a freaking
crowd it doesn't work like that yeah i'm
like bro i don't know what you want me
to do
yeah and then it's brothers though you
know yeah my brother's my brother's my
uh uh tour road manager oh okay it's the
same thing yeah so he's always telling
me that but then like you know you have
those people around you that you know
are like
hiding behind the scenes haters where
like they don't message you or say
anything to you but then it'll be like
after you win the place like oh they'll
post about you
my uncle there's nothing worse after my
first fight uncle was like
after i won my first fight he was like
oh well
if you lose the rest of your fights at
least you could say you won one in the
ufc okay that's not where we're going
i was like
it was like right after the win he's
like at least you gotta win huh and i
was like such a hater and i was like bro
and then now like we don't like we
barely talk but i'm like yeah you know
well you know i know you're a hater from
the beginning yeah they're either haters
they just don't understand like after i
did my first special on showtime my dad
didn't come it's a big deal and then the
next morning my dad calls me goes how'd
your speech go
all right well that's where we're at man
he apologized for that now i want that
on record he didn't apologize really but
yeah i think uh
you need that support and for you
especially the level you're at now you
know top five
again we're talking about before we got
these
egg roll mexican food where it's like
the the
the division's kind of it's in a weird
place man because
camaro and leon edwards supposed to
fight colby and hamza supposed to fight
potentially so let's say that happens
what do we do with muhammad you know
what i'm saying like then what happens
if if those
four fighters yeah that happens where
are you at you know what i'm saying like
yeah i mean
that literally leaves me on the outside
but then
for me
i'm a guy that's all right well if i
have to i know they never wanted to hand
me anything so if i have to go up five
four three two one four is gilbert burns
and
you know i don't think he really lost
any stock from uh beating comes i mean
losing the comments uh
i could i thought it could have went
either way so like if i have to go to
four three two one i'm like all right
let's go what about if they offer you
someone who's not ranked in top five
like a
like a like a
sean brady or something like that
for me i wouldn't do that because it's
like you get to this point right now
where
i had to call my way to this level right
now and it's like have you ever yeah and
then leon edwards man yeah you you boys
man you deserve it all yeah and i'm like
bro it's not like i was handed anything
there's guys that come to the ufc they
went two fights like it comes out and
then they're at the top right away or
like they're they're superstar right
away for me i was like bro i had to go
through the valleys the highs the lows
and
you guys didn't help build me like i
built myself up and even with my
for for myself is like
i started a podcast i did this and then
it's like all right you know my manager
stuff got me the spot as an analyst but
like you know i still earned that spot i
still got there it had to be good to be
an analyst 100 like for everything i did
i like i worked hard for every little
spot i have so i'm like i'm not going to
sit there and just give it away or just
go take a step backwards
yeah it's not worth the risk like you
work too hard to risk what you've built
on that
it's a good fight but you know
it has to be top five it's just
sometimes it's just the timing the
division which i would hate to see that
for you but then also when you talk
about you've earned it like
you know i i think too if i'm the ufc
and i don't know how their meetings go
down they kicked me a long time ago but
i think if they have their meetings
you know you're a guy who speaks well
right you just train your ass off you're
a good person so it's like
your history is something they can
really market but then also like you
know how hard it is to be to get an
analyst job in the ufc right like
everybody wants that job yeah everybody
man so for you to even be in the
rotation i mean you look at the guys who
are trying to get in there like it's a b
you have to be a real special skill set
man yeah and man it's a lot harder than
people think people think it's a lot
easier i'm like bro this is this is hard
and then i'm like a perfectionist so i'm
sitting there still thinking about man i
should have said this when it's like
that from like three weeks ago yeah and
i'm like looking up like broadcasting
schools and stuff like that because
it takes practice and it gets you know
it's it's different to be in front of a
camera and stuff like that but what
helps you is uh how long have you been
doing your podcast which is good yeah
about uh two years now two yeah so just
getting the the reps on that podcast
just to filter out like and flush ideas
out and engage and then also on podcasts
like
like probably the toughest like lifting
job i have is cal best fight campaign
you know it can be a three hour show
yeah so it's like that dead air you get
used to like filling that nobody's
better in the world than joe rogan
really i got buddies who are going to go
on like man where are we going to talk
about like trust me dude you don't have
to worry about it yeah let the captain
take the ship he'll he'll never have
that dead silence like you just from do
it from 10 for ten thousand hours they
always got some tools man yeah you know
so for you that you have such an
advantage because you're able to do that
podcast yeah and for like john when john
had first brought it to me he was like
always oh you got it we had to do a
podcast we got to do a podcast he's like
i want you to do with my brother jason
such a cool dude uh and then i was like
you know i don't want to do just like a
normal podcast i want to be different
because everybody has like their own
podcast or anything so that's why i made
it like a game show yeah uh so i had
like the game show aspect of it where
it's like if we do have that dead area
like yo all right let's start this game
show i feel like it opens up fighters
too where even with you where it's
something different where it's like yo
we're eating now we're just normally
talking instead of like all right so how
was the fight camp type interviews like
that how do you feel blah blah blah and
that that's my thing on this show like
um when i started show creators show i
i'm not a i think people get twisted i'm
not a journalist i'm not an expert i'm
just i have a background in fighting and
i know like what it takes to go through
it
but this show like i'm not breaking news
you know what i'm saying like i'm not
trying to get the story so like if you
came on here and you're like hey man uh
i want to talk about chicago pizza for
an hour like let's talk about chicago
pizza yeah i don't i'm interested in
what you can do fighting but if you told
me before it's like hey man i don't
really wanna talk about like cool let's
talk about kanye west for an hour i
don't give a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like there's no agenda here
that's just different about it yeah yeah
so it can go wherever you know
but yeah to that point i i think you
bring a lot to the table and ali knows
that you know he's a smart smart he's
one of the best in the game i love ali
he's a good dude he's a smart dude so
it's like you that you know ave won 10
out of 11. b you can talk your ass off
you're not an idiot so you like you
represent the sport good and as far as
you know whatever happens in your fight
career like this analyst stuff man you
know it's tough group to get in but you
can do it yeah you look at you look at a
guy like paul felder man
i mean unreal dude he he shouldn't be
that good yeah i train with paul felder
all the time and uh yeah seeing how much
he's grown from and like like he said
it's like now i can get paid and not get
punched in the face and i still in the
sport that i love and you know when you
leave the sport you're always like what
am i gonna do next when you see it all
the time like basketball and things like
that
where guys don't know what's next and
they're they're just lost so like to see
like their footsteps and talk with like
a dc or a pop out like yo how did you
guys get so good or how how does it feel
to be doing this now and they're like
bro just keep keep at it keep at it keep
growing because your foot's in the door
right now so you don't want to lose that
foot that you have in the door that's
the hardest part just your foot in the
door is the hardest part and then it's
on you like your opportunity to come who
knows rogan retires dc moves on who
knows yeah and then you're not silly
because you got you know you look at
dominic cruz
you got felder um and you got bisping
bismuth freaking great you know what i'm
saying yeah so you got yet like these
monsters man just like waiting in the in
the shadows for the opportunity they're
getting them and you're right there man
yeah but is it tough for you because you
know you had like you and not every
fighter can say this [ __ ] 99.9 can't say
this like you know you have this career
over here if you want with podcast
analysts you know but then also you're
chasing a world title those other guys
you're fighting like hamzad don't give a
[ __ ] about the podcast game you know
what i'm saying yeah so you know he's
focused on this you know so for you do
you feel like it's
it gets pulling you a little bit it gets
a little bit when uh finding guests
because that like i don't know that's
the first i don't know nobody i
literally slide into dms
24 7. i don't care if like you you
turned me down or anything did you slide
into mine dude i think i said it's your
df god damn i was like and i was like
i literally slid into everybody's dms
and that's the way i get it you know
i'll have like i've had huge names i'm
not sure i had paul fell down my show i
had chris wyman frankie edgar uh darren
till so like i've had those guys on my
show but then you'll get people on like
on twitter oh ali probably got him those
guys and i'm like bro like i was sliding
your dms if you don't respond to my
damns i go in your comments hey yo could
you come on my podcast and that's how i
got chidoverra oh
[ __ ] like didn't respond to my dm but he
responded to my comment she's the best
and i just got karate hottie uh last
week where she's like it was like a year
later
it was like a year later she's like oh
i'm sorry i just saw this she's all i'm
in you're like yeah last three years
literally i was like bro all right well
you're you're in so i'll take it but i
was like yo this is like a year ago
there's that's the worst part i don't
think people understand like when you
have a especially what i like after so
many guests on all the shows it's the
worst part of the game yeah it's not the
one and then if for the reason like
thank god on my level now where i have
people that book guys you know but in
general like sometimes it comes down to
me and i'm like hey man do you mind like
you just like [ __ ] yeah away from
people's schedule and [ __ ] you know for
you i think it's gonna be easier for you
because you're at this level now but i'm
like bro it's a beast man yeah it's hard
and i'm like
and we like it'll be like thursday my
show's on thursday and i won't have a
guess and i made the game show myself i
like literally do like face mashes and
stuff like that of uh like filters and
like funny stuff like that and i haven't
done that editing yeah i'm doing that
yeah i'm doing all of that and i'm like
all right we ain't got no guts yet so
i'll literally slide into a million dm's
at one time then there'll be times where
i like have four people respond at one
time and i'm like all right we're going
four people on the show oh damn instead
of like wasting it bank them yeah yeah
instead of like wasting them so i'm like
bro
and it's cool because like every time
somebody comes on and they they're done
they're always like messing me up yo
that was a great thing great show it's a
different show and then having like i
had chelsea on his show and he's like
genius and like just getting those
messages makes you like feels happy
about it when you have guys at that
level tell you that yeah i think the for
me it's like you and i haven't met
before i've always been a fan i became a
fan
i knew you're a monster fighter i became
a fan when you start doing the the desk
gig
let's do smart i'm main man like i dig
that because nobody can do that but then
with your fighting
the problem with this show is because
you and i are be boys now so i'll root
for you the problem is when you fight a
guy like colby i'm boys
like i love the vicente lucas i love
this he's like the nicest guy in the
world so it's like once guys are on the
show and i create a relationship with
them and then if you guys have to fight
i'm like oh [ __ ] and then i go on my
shop show that you know they forced me
to make preparations
and you'll see like
especially like your next fight if you
fight somebody i know i'll just skate
right in the middle really yeah you know
i think muhammad gots this one but if
you know it's like i don't want to piss
anybody off yeah it's like a tough gig
it's fine for me because i do like i
circle picks for every week
yeah like it got to the point where fans
now are always like what are your picks
this week and i do the whole card and
then uh ali like had like a
uh you know a big thing where all of his
fighters were on the uh he brought them
all out to vegas for like an event with
like uh interviews and stuff like that
and then i forgot what his name was some
big russian heavyweight like walked up
to me he's like you know circled me my
last fight and i was like i don't even
know you look at my pics
yeah so now i'm like look at that like
fighters are paying attention to it and
then like i had uh gigan jacassi like
came up to me he said how come you
didn't circle my teammate and i was like
bro i don't know i had to be here yeah i
don't even know you like that yeah
there's a lot of pressure but i know you
now and i'm like bro all right there's a
reason why certain guys in the business
don't make picks yeah because they don't
want the backlash for me it's like ah
sorry man it's a draftings thing like i
have to do it yeah yeah it's no shade
dude it's it's all it gets hard and then
especially if you're like you start
knowing people or you meet somebody and
then you know it's a terrible matchup
for them and i was like well i gotta i'm
picking i always have my uncle well nice
to meet like yo are these real pics are
you picking with your heart or are these
guys your friends i'm like yeah these
are heart picks it's not my head picks
right now i tell people all the time no
never bet on my picks because i i i i
pick with my heart never if it was my
brain people are going to hate me
because you want me to break it down
because then you know you got to break
down their losses and like footwork and
mechanics like i don't like doing that i
just tell people you know i'll do the
draftkings read and stuff but don't
listen to my picks man i think guys that
i have relationships with and you know
yeah that's the i mean but like when i
get to the point now where i'm at the
level where every week it's like what
are your picks what do you think and
then when you start making those picks
out of those and you're they're wrong
you're like bro i had like three bad
weeks in a row but i'm like bro i'm
picking all the fights like there's like
12 fights and then
you you your picks suck but then you get
like
funny guys like college wrestlers and
stuff that'll message me like bro your
picks have been losing me money
i'm like i'm glad you guys are all
paying attention though yeah it's funny
because it's just like so surprising
when you get those
messages or somebody from like a comment
from somebody big like oh this guy who's
this guy i don't know this guy even
follows me or he checks me out so it's
like cool yeah yeah there's pressure
with the pigs yeah you gotta get dicey
with that so for you
we're talking a little bit off air about
it for you as far as your next fight
it's kind of i almost and don't take
this wrong with no distract it's almost
i mean it's a common theme in prayer
it's almost not up to you
you know what i'm saying like you're at
the mercy of this weird
four-man tournament going on upstairs
you know what i'm saying above you still
then it's like you're at five
yeah that's the
and for me like i understand it and it's
like like
i understand the business part of it i'm
like obviously comes that's the biggest
name and you want to get him
the the biggest fight so if there's an
enter in fight i feel like they're going
to try to give it to him
and it's like i'm not going to sit there
and go online and like pout about it you
don't want to bash him but is there a
part of you
you know obviously he didn't take the
same road that you took like you took a
different path and it was probably like
dude come on man yeah it's you know
that's my part and then because i had a
million people come up to me too where i
would call them on twitter and they'd be
like how are you going to call out
another muslim and i'm like bro it's not
about muslim against muslims it's like
yeah that's not yeah we're not about
religion this is about he wants it i
want it too so i like if we're if i see
him at the moment you know hey what's up
how are you doing blah blah blah we're
fighting we're fighting and it's like
it's a professional sport so when i tell
people that yo we both want the same
thing we're both grinding for the same
thing like you said
i you know you had that mentality like
oh man how come this guy got it so easy
or how come this guy's blown up he only
has three fights and he's already number
two in the world how come they gave him
that for 21. i've been asking for the
opportunity forever yeah but it's like
where are you at on that it's like i had
to mentally like tell myself like yo
there's a path for everything and like
being a religious guy it's like god's
plan is
his plan his plan is bigger than your
plan and that's how i see it now yeah my
plan is different i also think guys this
advice i'd give you and you know i've
been through some [ __ ] if you put energy
into that
you're going to lose focus on what
really matters like
all right they want to dana and those
guys want to build up bombs out that's
their guy right now cool man you can't
control that yeah you can't control
anything so anything i can control i
don't put any energy in yeah i'm trying
to do my [ __ ] over here this takes so
much effort and focus all right i can't
control that i'm gonna focus over here
yeah and that's like the beautiful thing
about having other things to do where
you're not getting stressed out about it
you're not waiting at home like oh
what's next what's next what's next
you're like all right well i can do this
right now i can stay busy with this or
like i'm trying to get into other
businesses as well where it's like i
don't have to sit there and focus like
man when is the ufc going to call me i
need that check at this moment otherwise
i can't eat and it's like well if you
guys want to do that i'll wait for
something better to come along yeah what
i love about you is like you know if you
look at like uh sugar shawn or uh patty
pimlet like those guys make more money
you know off
you know the stuff they do on social
media or parents just yeah you know than
they do fighting knock on with you i
don't see you getting on twitch and
playing video games like yeah for you
you're more of a businessman yeah yeah i
think it's going to be a entrepreneurial
kind of vision for you yeah and that's
like i think that was just the way i was
raised where i said like
my dad's had his own business my
brothers had their own business my
cousins all had like their own business
and it's
that's that was always like the path so
like for me now it's like all right well
i know i'm capable of doing that so
i had three brothers so like we're now
trying to build an empire like yes let's
do this this and this and then i don't
even have to be in charge of this like
i'm getting money now where you're
associated with it yeah where i i you
guys should do it show it to me what you
guys want to do and we'll build it
together and obviously i could use my
name on it or whatever like that but
we have the money now now when i was
younger it was like well we need to do
this we need to work for this person or
that person and you know your mom's
always telling you go to school they
like immigrant moms think that school is
what's what you what's needed that's how
you're successful if you graduate from
college and that's the only way to be
successful so it's like now we can do
that without that yeah and we could show
that
it's not like anything's possible if you
just grind it yeah i think with like
athletes or
i'll why use athletes for example but
it's like uh like you look at the
ufc career it's like dude that's such a
short time in your life man so it's like
guys like oh i was too focused on
fighting i couldn't do this other stuff
it's like man that's such a that's a
chapter a small chapter in your life and
guys get so attached to being labeled
ufc fighter it's like that's just
something you do man like that that's
not your identity like if if you if that
was just your identity you're not doing
your podcast and looking at these other
businesses so it's like this ufc right
now is taking your focus on your energy
and you're crushing it but
okay like this is gonna be such a short
chapter in your life like those
businesses and you have kids and all
that [ __ ] like that's the story that's
your life ufc is a cool experience
that's why i look at it like i guess if
you're like uh you know a gsp or
something around for [ __ ] ever like
that's different this is a whole book
for the majority guys even if you're
there for six seven eight years like
eight years that's such a short chapter
dude yeah
and like you said i think a lot of guys
don't understand it and they're like and
even when they lose a fight it hurts
them so hard because there's like that's
i need it that's it what do i do now but
this is this is what goes back to your
roots like your family instilled that in
you you know what i'm saying like you
know like you see the work ethic your
dad has your brothers so you it's like
you know you've seen them put the plan
together in the discipline and be
successful at that you're like oh that's
how that works all right i'll get there
you know what i'm saying like that's
always there for you yeah that's all
that's your mom and dad shout out to
your mom and dad yeah shout out to them
and now shout out to mama even for like
one guy i get that all the time like how
do you make it to the ufc or how do you
do this how do you and i'm telling
people like bro don't think that
fighting is gonna be an easy path like i
had my coach lewis taylor uh we've been
together since high school he was uh my
high school wrestling coach and
he was literally knocking everybody out
he had like i think a 15 fight winning
streak of all first round finishes
mm-hmm and mma never got a shot in the
ufc but he was like 40 years old and
then i was sitting there you know he's
my mentor so i'm looking at like
this guy's knocking people out he's not
getting a shot in the ufc how am i gonna
get my shot in the ufc if he's not gonna
get shot and then you know he finally
gets his call with the pfl
the first uh tournament for the million
dollars
still 42 years old now and it's like
he's won his first fight when's the
second fight he goes against the russian
in the finals knocks him out in 30
seconds wins a million dollars oh damn
yeah he was the first middleweight
champion for piano yeah he was a fruit
like i said it was like he has like kind
of like the yo romero body where it's
like
he doesn't lift any weights but he just
like jacked jack this heck and like
would walk around at like 189 pounds
wouldn't have to cut weight
yeah just strong
want to have a seat
literally i'm like
every time we get we're going out
because i got you with a lot of mexican
guys they'll look at him like oh you're
going to choose me yeah he's like
nothing what are you talking about
he just literally just started older
yeah he started older so how did him pf
you became the ps4
shot did he get a ufc shot
that was the last fight and uh so he
retired undefeated world champion yeah
no well he lost uh he's lost like two or
three fights but he retired in pfl
middleweight champion uh that was his
last fight his whole family was there at
that square garden oh my god yeah and
it's like you want man when he was
telling me that all the time people were
like bro you gotta you want a million
dollars in 30 seconds no i want a
million dollars in 12 years
grinding where i like i had moments
where i didn't think i was gonna make it
and you know getting paid a thousand and
a thousand trying to support my family
but it was all about the dream it was
all about the grinding and it's like
real champion if you're not willing to
have that mentality oh i don't care what
it what it takes to get there i'm going
to take it so like
seeing his story is like the craziest
thing ever because that's dope man yeah
sounds like a good dude yeah you're sure
the this is the other common theme with
you as you're talking you're surrounded
by great people yeah yeah yeah like
people that are in your country they
really care a small team yeah i've had
gems i've been to gyms where like you
lose the fight
they're not sitting and knocking at your
door they don't really care they're like
not the focus anymore yeah they're all
right we'll move on to the next super
next guy yeah and it's hard
you're like man who's who's with me when
i lose yeah because those are the ones
that really matter those are the people
and that's your family or like your
close close friends that really like how
you feeling today's three days later and
the world's telling you you suck yes but
doesn't want to settle next to you like
yeah man yeah i think and for you like
this long journey you've taken to get to
number five in the world your next fight
is either a title eliminator you know
i'm saying that you're like one fight
maybe you're right [ __ ] there for
you've taken the perfect path and you
have the perfect kind of
not to shame like entourage around you
like the perfect team around you to get
this done it's just they just have to
find
like you're you're this puzzle piece
that they need to
figure out you know what i'm saying yeah
and and the people that suffer from this
whole
weird welterweight puzzle is you and
leon edwards i think yeah i think so too
so like you could
do that rematch and then you get poked
in the eye yeah i gotta be honest i and
again i love both of you guys i don't
know leon personally i think
technical wise there's there's
it would be tough to find better right
now in the water division like his
techniques
yes and people i respect like josh
thompson like dude i'm telling you this
kid is the real he's been saying it
forever and i respect josh right
but i i don't know like that fight you
and him if it happens great if that
works for you yeah i'm just not excited
for it i want you to get homs i want you
to get colby i don't get gusman
obviously that's the thing that's the
hard part because nowadays it's about
like what's going to get you the most
shine or what's going to get the fans
most riled up you know leon obviously is
a great fighter and fighters know how
good he is phenomenal but like the fans
don't really know him because he doesn't
post anything it doesn't go on social
media crazy anything like that and the
one time that you know with the nate
diaz fight like he's winning
he win the fight every second if i
except for the last three seconds it's
clipped yeah and then the narrative
because nate diaz fan base is so big
there was like bro if this was a stream
fight yeah this thing's over it's like
wait what but it's not this this was
inside doctor on a professional sport he
lost every single round dude i tell
people like i was like
yeah
i'm like yo they're trying they're
basically put on a silver platter yo
beating ideas steal his fans and then
like you said you get rocked and they're
like seconds thirty years oh my god leon
that poor guy dude i said i'm like bro
if he has the title for to get used to
something's gonna happen he's gonna trip
over the freaking wires as he's walking
out
like literally has the worst luck such a
shame man yeah yeah so it's like that
could possibly happen for you and it's
like that doesn't happen i don't know
dude i don't know at least you're in a
good spot though yeah i mean for me i
think comes out makes the most sense at
everybody like
even if you want to play the muslim
cardio two muslim fighters headline a
card abu dhabi
i think that'll be huge and it's a great
idea
has he said anything about the light
we've gone back and forth on twitter
before and you know now i think he's at
the level now where he probably has
people tweeting for him because it's
like let me post the title fight or let
me just post the title or let me post
like
ah the wolf is coming you know with the
nate diaz and the conor mcgregor
they won't tweet nothing forever then
they'll just tweet something and the
fans go what does he mean by this what's
going on yeah and i'm like bro conor
mcgregor's not even in a testing pool i
don't think he's gonna fight yeah this
year so for you to think that this tweet
means something it's just like i want
attention it's like i'm bored right now
i'm chilling at home let me get the fans
riled up and i think that comes up to
that level now too where he's like let
me just tweet something to get fans
talking and when when you watch the
hamza gilbert burns fight what was your
takeaway
i saw i saw weaknesses and i saw that
you know
obviously people are like oh man he's
he's not as good as we thought he was
but i'm like yo he showed that he has a
chin he showed that he got power and
it's like you're fighting gilbert burns
he's a dog yeah i'm like i picked them i
circled the other burns and i had so
many people like you're a liar you don't
even think everybody's gonna win you're
just picking him because he's with ali
and i'm like bro gilbert is number two
in the world why do you think that he's
just gonna walk through gilbert burns
obviously you know he had what a five
first round finishes whatever and savage
yeah he's he's obviously good but i'm
like bro
what was he 11 13 11 the number was
what's his giveaway time two two yeah
it's a dude that's such a big jump yeah
like though you top five guys like it's
such a different animal and i think
uh nobody was higher on homs that i was
just like dude this guy's insane yeah
he's the next coming of you know gs this
guy's a monster
and then i saw that
it's i i don't think his stock went down
my takeaway was he didn't listen his
coaches he did what he thought he could
do which like get into brag in a war no
game plan he still passed the test
but now the caveat on that is if hamza
doesn't learn from that like you got
lucky yeah like if that was anybody else
you you have taken an l so i think his
team and he has some phenomenal coaches
hamzad has to go in going all right i
can't just keep shooting from the hip i
have to stick to a game plan so if he
does get you he gets colby or something
like that it there has to be a game plan
there has to be execution of the game
plan or he's going to lose yeah yeah and
i think i think he has the dog he has
the talent but you do 11 to 2 is such a
big jump and when you get to that i
think when people don't understand it
when you get the top five if you're not
you know fighting with the strategy
you're gonna lose to the good guys for
me i think that these last three fights
i've showed that i could fight with a
strategy because they're all different
fighters i thought damien maya who's i
had to stay up on my feet i cannot get
taken down so it's all defensive
wrestling then i fought wonder boy who's
like i'm not going to kickbox with a
wonderboy so i'm going to go in there
and take one boy down he's not easy to
take down yeah not a guy easy to take
down and i don't have college wrestling
i'm not a division 1 wrestler but fight
with a strategy yep and i dominated him
more than anybody else has ever
dominated him then you fight a guy like
luke who's knocked me out who has the
most finishes in welterweight savage and
you're like he's good on his feet and
good on the ground how are you gonna be
the guy like that oh well with movement
footwork and then shooting in when he
least expects it when he thinks you're
gonna wrestle you shoot uh you strike
when he thinks you're gonna strike you
shoot yeah being smart man yeah and i
did that so like i showed that i could
be a different fighter in every single
fight and i think that comes that's
teams looking at that like bruh you know
what let's look for somebody else at
this moment let's not try to jump on
that because if kobe's out and i'm
willing to fight you we can fight in
june we can fight in july i'm i'm ready
to go yep why aren't you guys willing to
step up that quick so i think it's more
so like coach yeah you know let's let's
wait and see let's let's check this out
first
yeah again he's in a he's in a good spot
don't get around because he's in a
different spot than you just because you
have you have the experience you've been
through the grind you've been to
implement different game plans and beat
guys that you know who are specialists
in one thing and you're able to strike
this one wrestle this one and for him
it's like he hasn't gone through that
process so as much as i think a lot
against the division envy him i don't
because it's same thing happened with
darren till it's like when you get to
the top there's really nowhere to go my
man yeah you just beat the number two
guy but we can't give you number eight
can't give you number nine it's gonna be
one of the top five guys and these guys
have been through hell man so you might
fancy yourself a brawler you can't brawl
they're not gonna brawl with you you're
not gonna have an opportunity in any
faster to browse them finish yourself a
wrestler
these guys can wrestle you know so it's
like for him he has to learn
on the go and you're in the top five so
i don't envy that i think he can pass
the test and he has a good he has the
skills do it in the talent to do it i
think he will be a he's a monster right
now but i just think to live up this
potential they put so much pressure on
him and it's like to me i'm like oh man
if you could just slow it down just a
tad yeah and but like that might be the
dad of me you know no but like you said
like we've seen it happen with the guy
there until we're here
he's so talented he's next in line this
is the guy this is the guy then he loses
then all of a sudden the losses start
piling up and then kamda you said he's
very young he's you know you could have
built them up way better than that and
maybe i think they were thinking about
that like yo let's just give them this
nate diaz fight real quick throw them up
a little more let them dominate a guy
like nate diaz but they just ain't dumb
he knows what you're trying to do to him
you're trying to he was still down
though yeah but like he's not gonna sit
there and i think they were going back
and forth but i don't think you
realistically yeah if i'm nate and i am
yeah like i'm gonna let this savage
build his name off me as my last one to
go fight you know jake paul or something
like that yeah but i mean with nate diaz
is like yo if i don't get finished he
won
ideas
and i was talking to uh jake shields too
and he told me that
nate's not afraid nate's down oh yeah no
yeah i would never assume nate's a
friend yeah and i'm like all right cause
you know you whatever win or lose you're
still gonna have that fan base and you
go win 50 million dollars to fight jake
paul oh he could lose 10 fights in a row
yeah he just has that unique fan base
that they just love what he represents
yeah god bless him that's great like
what level what what do you need to do
to get that fan base though and that's
like the the goal is where like you're
graduating
you lose five in a row people don't
understand that yo this guy's still
losing but oh conor mcgregor tweets out
title fight let me give it some nick
diaz teach out to kamara usman oh man
nick diaz should fight kamara usman and
you're like what are these and the fans
are about yeah i'm like yeah what are
you talking about right now like how how
does this make sense it's a good
question i don't know yeah i don't know
if in 2022 if you can do it i don't know
i don't know if it's capable now you
know what i'm saying yeah i mean what i
think a guy that's showing me that he's
capable is petty pimplet where it's like
it was i was with him in
arizona great guy he's a good dude he's
such a good dude yeah but it was like
the fans were like asking for pictures
and he'd just like run inside the the
hotel
and i was sitting there outside taking
pictures with him getting selfies doing
face-offs and then he was like yo i got
a scheduled uh i gotta schedule the
picture at the which call the at the
fights in front of the arena like
scheduled that i'm gonna get paid for at
this and i'm sitting there like
he walked out the fans are going nuts
and i'm like bro how's he getting this
much love i'm standing outside the hotel
in the heat swept my ass off yeah taking
a picture every single one of you guys
and you guys are sitting there freaking
blowing this guy up and just ran in the
hotel i'm like how does it make sense i
think i think for patty it's like you
know
and i i i could be honest you know i'm
balls deep hardcore and mma like i knew
he was big out there in liverpool yeah
and then when we did a food truck with
him in san diego i'm talking to his
manager who's a great guy
and
he's like dude like
he didn't need the ufc like he was
selling out arenas on my show like in
liverpool like he can't walk down the
street yeah and i was like really i've
never seen a bigger star man and you
remember he's had darren till through
there uh hardy conor mcgregor i think
bisbee came out like the who soon he's
like i've never seen a bigger star yeah
i was like what and he was like yeah we
call him the fifth beatle i was like
jesus christ being in arizona i was
sitting there like is this good that was
my first time ever meeting him but i was
sitting there like nah the people in the
states don't really know him like that
but like he walked out and he got the
biggest cheer i think he was even more
than sean o'malley and sean o'malley's
like hometown's hometown yeah and i'm
like
all right this guy is real but then you
got people
still think that you know he can knock
out charlie's oliveira now like but that
doesn't make sense this is what's great
about patty is
you and you'll you don't have guys come
on and they're young guys and if you
talk i'm sure you've talked on the show
like oh yeah i want to fight you know
like you know if it's some young guy not
i'm not saying paddy did it's like oh
yeah i want to fight uh justin gaichi
and you're like bro you have two fights
in the ufc yeah patty's not like that
patty's literally like uh yeah it's a
marathon not a sprint man so i make more
fighting outside doctor than i do
fighting so unless the fight's right i'm
not doing [ __ ] yeah i know i got some
[ __ ] to work on but as far as grappling
goes i'll grapple with anybody like he
what i love about him is it's so
authentic and he's aware of what's going
on how big he is but it doesn't get to
his head like he's good yeah you know
he's like i just believe i have a
different skill set you know and i i'm
gonna get there but
there's no rush yeah oh [ __ ] dude
honestly a lot of guys can learn even
like
me i'm learning stuff from him yeah as
i'm just like sitting there just staring
at him and i'm sitting there like you
said like making so much money
without fighting and he's like all right
well i'm charging you for this
appearance i'm charging you for this oh
i'm not going to do this interview
unless that's the takeaway that's the
takeaway when i was talking because i
get close with the manners right because
you know the the fighters being miked up
wherever like if ali came i love ollie i
mean him talked a bunch he he does
wonders for you guys he's a monster
and it was uh patty's um manager i'm
just talking to him and he's like yeah
man he's telling me what they usually
charge for
interviews like basic interviews he's
like yeah we've had some problems with
big journalists because you know we're
over in england and bt sport one
interview so like yeah i mean there's
how much cost to interview him like what
he's the guys play other athletes like
you know soccer players and rugby and
football basketball like
he's as big as they are pay him dude
he's getting paid yeah and in my it
changed i'm like more guys should do
this man like you get to a certain level
it's like you're giving all your time
all your time and remember like
you're they're getting views off you
they're getting paid from those views
you know
yeah no i mean and it makes sense and i
was about that level i i think i was at
the level where i just started learning
it now because like i had somebody like
messaging me like yo could you do a meet
and greet in uh detroit in dearborn
michigan shout out to them because
there's a big palestinian community over
there and then i was like oh yeah for
sure i'll come down and uh they're like
what's your appearance fee and i was
like i don't know what it is
for free i was like yeah i was like i
don't know what an appearance really is
because like i said i'm happy that
somebody wants to like people want to
you know talk to me and yeah
yeah but i was just like god bless you
yeah yeah like you're such a nice guy i
was like an appearance feed but i was
like uh let me talk to my manager and i
never hit up ali but i was just like yo
if you guys just find me on i'm good and
they were like oh well we'll give you
the uh i'll give you this amount and i
was like alright cool and then i was
like so happy with it i'm like tell my
brother yo these guys are paying me to
come out there and then uh i talked to
ali and like khabib did the appearance
for them the week before yeah man yeah i
could be out there the week before and
then i talked about like oh yeah i'm
doing the same one he's like oh are you
brother i was like yeah yeah they
messaged me he's like why what are they
praying he's like brother you are so
stupid i was like what
let ali use the leverage of those guys
and get you paid yeah god damn you're
such a nice guy though that's what
happens man i was like
it was so fun though so well i i think
whatever happens is your next fight man
you get you're gonna start getting paid
for appearances that's for freaking sure
especially doing those meet and greets
where was it detroit or something
yesterday what are we doing yeah i was
like oh man well i paid you in a mexican
ad growth hope they're good man but uh
dude i i've always been a fan from the
outside man i love what you're doing the
podcast if i can ever help you know you
got my number man let me know brother
keep crushing it i think uh
you know there's a big fight for you we
just gotta you know figure it out at the
top and then
for the food truck diaries i always have
my boys at suplex in philly
fly out a shoe i picked the shoe
personally now you you came in here with
some fire ass yeezys and i don't have
those and i really want them now so
suplex send those blue yeezys but uh
this is for you my man for doing the
show
these are
ah
fire reds man the ogs original box
everything my man you're in chicago
what are we doing here in chicago
thank you my brother appreciate you yeah
and your sneakers are dope
dope on you man yeah these are dope it's
funny because uh when i was younger uh
one of my best friends used to buy
jordans all the time and uh my mom would
never buy it for me and i was like all
right now when i get older i literally
buy shoes non-stop just because and i
like won't even wear them but i'll buy
them just because i never had them when
i was a kid my friend just to have all
the jordans and everything and i was
like you know i'm gonna buy that now i
can afford them now and i'm like so
stupid when i buy them and they just sit
down didn't collect dust but these are
for you my man thank you brother
appreciate you my best
uh appreciate you brother thanks for
doing the show keep crushing my man
[Music]
super thick boy